se creaba un suspenso
porque a los tuits reales,
uno no controlaba cuándo los leería.
Venían a un ritmo bastante regular,
pero a medida que se desarrolla la historia,
normalmente, como lector, uno controla el ritmo de lectura,
pero en este caso, lo hacía The New Yorker
y hacían entregas poquito a poco,
y uno sentía el suspenso de esperar la próxima línea.
Otro gran ejemplo de ficción
y de cuento en Twitter.
Elliot Holt es la escritora que escribió el cuento "Evidence".
Empieza con este tuit: "El 28 de noviembre
a las 22:13 hs,
una mujer identificada como Miranda Brown,
44 años, de Brooklyn, cae desde
la azotea de un hotel de Manhattan y muere".
Empieza con la voz de Elliott,
pero luego su voz se aleja
y escuchamos las voces de Elsa, Margot y Simon,
personajes que Elliott creó en Twitter
específicamente para contar esta historia,
una historia con múltiples aristas
que llevan a este momento de las 22:13 hs
cuando esta mujer cae y muere.
Estos tres personajes crean una visión auténtica
de varios puntos de vista.
Un crítico llamó al cuento de Elliott
"Ficción en Twitter bien hecha", porque lo hizo.
Capturó esa voz
tuvo múltiples personajes y sucedió en tiempo real.
Curiosamente, sin embargo, Twitter
no era solo un mecanismo de distribución.
También era un mecanismo de producción.
Elliott me dijo después
que escribió todo con sus pulgares.
Recostada en el sofá iba y venía
tecleando distintos caracteres
tuiteando cada línea, línea por línea.
Creo que esta especie de creación espontánea
de lo que salía de las voces de los personajes
realmente le confirió autenticidad a los personajes en sí,
pero también a este formato que ella creó
de múltiples aristas en un cuento de Twitter.
Conforme uno empieza a jugar con la identidad flexible online
se pone cada vez más interesante
cuando uno empieza a interactuar con el mundo real.
Cosas como Invisible Obama
o el meme "binders full of women"
que aparecieron en la campaña electoral del 2012
o incluso el universo de fans en Twitter de "West Wing"
en el que están todas estas cuentas
una para cada personaje de "The West Wing",
estaba hasta el pájaro que en un episodio
golpea la ventana de Josh Lyman. (Risas)
Son todas iteraciones rápidas sobre un tema.
Son gente creativa que experimenta
con los límites de lo posible en este medio.
Vemos cosas como "West Wing" Twitter,
en la que personajes de ficción
interactúan con el mundo real.
Hablan de política,
despotrican contra el Congreso.
Recuerden son todos demócratas.
E interactúan con el mundo real.
Le responden.
Entonces, si tomamos la identidad flexible,
el anonimato, la interacción con el mundo real,
y sobrepasamos el simple homenaje o la parodia
y ponemos todo eso al servicio de narrar una historia,
ahí la cosa se pone muy interesante.
Durante la elección de la alcaldía de Chicago
había una cuenta de parodia.
Era Mayor Emanuel.
Te daba todo lo que querías de Rahm Emanuel,
sobre todo las blasfemias.
Esta cuenta malhablada
seguía las actividades diarias de la campaña
y comentaba lo ocurrido.
Seguía la retórica normal
de una cuenta de parodia buena y sólida,
pero luego empezó a volverse extraña.
Conforme avanzaba, pasó de ese comentario
a una épica de ciencia ficción en tiempo real de varias semanas
en la que el protagonista, Rahm Emanuel,
emprende un viaje multidimensional el día de la elección
que... nunca ocurrió.
Verifiqué en los periódicos.
Y luego, muy interesante, llegó a su fin.
Esto es algo que no sucede por lo general
con una cuenta de parodia en Twitter.
Termina con una verdadera conclusión narrativa.
El escritor Dan Sinker, periodista,
era completamente anónimo todo este tiempo.
Creo que para Dan era importante
convertir esto en un libro,
porque al final era un formato narrativo,
y creo que convertirlo en libro
es un signo de que creó algo nuevo
que había que traducir a los formatos previos.
Uno de mis ejemplos favoritos
de algo que está ocurriendo ahora en Twitter,
es el muy absurdo Crimer Show.
Crimer Show cuenta la historia
de un súpercriminal y un detective desventurado
que se enfrentan con un lenguaje muy extraño,
con los lugares comunes de la tele.
El creador de Crimer Show dijo que
es una parodia de un tipo popular de espectáculo del Reino Unido,
pero, hombre, es extraño.
Crimer, el súpercriminal,
hace todo lo típico de la TV:
siempre se quita las gafas de sol
o gira hacia la cámara,
pero todo esto sucede en el texto.
Creo que tomar todos estos lugares comunes de la tele
y además presentar cada Crimer Show
como un episodio, deletreado E-P-P-A-S-O-D [parodia promo de tv]
presentándolos como episodios
realmente crea algo nuevo.
Hay un nuevo "epasodio" de Crimer Show
en Twitter casi a diario,
y se archivan así.
Creo que esto es un experimento interesante con el formato.
Algo totalmente nuevo creado
a partir de la parodia de algo de la tele.
Creo que en la narrativa de no ficción en tiempo real
también hay muchos ejemplos excelentes.
RealTimeWWII es una cuenta
que documenta lo ocurrido hoy pero hace 60 años
con un detalle excepcional como si
uno leyera las noticias de ese día.
Y el escritor Teju Cole experimentó
mucho con eso de darle un giro literario
a las noticias.
En este caso particular, está hablando de ataques con drones.
Creo que en ambos ejemplos
empezamos a ver formas
de narrativa con contenido de no ficción
que pueden constituir nuevos tipos
de narrativa de ficción.
Así, la narrativa en tiempo real
difumina la línea entre realidad y ficción,
el mundo real y el mundo digital,
la identidad flexible, el anonimato,
son herramientas que tenemos a mano,
y creo que son solo bloques de construcción.
Son elementos que usamos
para crear estructuras, marcos,
sobre las cuales apoyar la exploración
de esta frontera abierta a la experimentación.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)